in 1991 Mount Pinatubo in the
Philippines erupted becoming the second
largest volcanic eruption of the 20th
century it s Ash plume shot up past the
atmosphere and into the stratosphere
dispersing a layer of aerosol particles
around the whole world those particles
formed a sort of solar umbrella that
reflected sunlight away from the earth
and caused global temperatures to drop
by about half a degree Celsius for
almost two years it's not the first
massive volcanic eruption to cool global
temperatures El chichon volcano lowered
temperatures by a similar amount in 1982
as did other major eruptions over the
past Century
today scientists have been exploring
whether we could replicate this
phenomenon to fight global warming using
a technology called solar geoengineering
supporters say it's a tool we need to
seriously explore as climate change
worsens understanding more about these
things could potentially reduce
suffering that's worth a lot but critics
believe the Technology's risks outweigh
its rewards and shouldn't be a response
to fighting global warming sometimes
more technology is not always better
there are some things that have been
invented that a lot of people would wish
had never been invented so which one is
it
to understand the benefits and risks of
solar geoengineering I spoke to several
scientists lawyers indigenous Leaders
with strong opinions on both sides with
Stakes as high as the survival of the
human race on Earth should we be
exploring solar geoengineering
there's one thing scientists all agree
on solar geoengineering could cool down
the planet reflecting sunlight away from
the earth stops heat from getting
trapped in our atmosphere we could do
that by injecting aerosols into the
stratosphere like volcanoes can do
that's the most commonly researched
approach some scientists are also
looking into brightening Marine clouds
so they're better at reflecting the Sun
and other potential methods include
reflective shields in outer space these
initiatives are still in different
stages of the research phase but in
order for us to deploy these
Technologies and get large-scale cooling
effects we'd need to interfere with our
complex climate on a massive scale
one of the main reasons some scientists
support solar geoengineering is that
we're currently on a pretty dire path
our emissions mainly carbon dioxide keep
Rising there's really no question we
must cut emissions in the long run but
even if you cut emissions to zero
tomorrow that does not eliminate climate
risk it just means you stop the climate
risk getting worse as the climate risk
comes from accumulated emissions that's
University of Chicago Professor David
Keith he explained to me that unless we
think Beyond emission reduction the
climate change impacts were already
experiencing will continue to worsen
a recent study showed that extreme
weather accounted for nearly 10 percent
of all Global deaths and shows an
increase in heat related ones to
mitigate those effects supporters argue
that we need to explore climate
processes use computer modeling and
develop technology to figure out if and
maybe how this technology could safely
be deployed globally along with other
Solutions
the thing is messing with our global
climate is very complicated
the whole climate system is wired
together people
could technologically speak and create
major uh unpredictable changes in the
way the climate system responds Oxford
Professor Raymond Pierre Humbert is
referencing one of the big concerns
about solar geoengineering adding new
elements into our atmosphere or
Stratosphere will change precipitation
patterns across the world potentially
worsening the extreme weather we're
already experiencing due to climate
change nearly everyone agrees on these
risks and you can't actually answer the
most significant questions about the
climate system response short of a
full-scale deployment a full-scale
deployment would require unprecedented
Global cooperation not just in terms of
scale but in terms of time I think
carbon dioxide we have emitted since the
Industrial Revolution and we admit today
we'll continue to have a warming effect
on climate for thousands of years from
now even if we stop omitting but in
contrast the solar geoengineering
techniques proposed have a very short
Lifetime and the atmosphere to create a
continued cooling effect we would need
to deploy them constantly for centuries
that means that you're committed to
having institutions and treaties that
can be adhered to for thousands of years
and that's a really
unprecedented sort of burden to put on
future Humanity if there's an
international disagreement War Global
depression or something that forces a
sudden termination of solar
geoengineering then the world gets hit
with this rapid warming that rapid
warming is called termination shock and
the risk of it happening is one of the
big reasons critics think solar
geoengineering is ungovernable and
unsustainable
and so far we have a pretty poor record
of figuring out how to move things
forward in 2021 Sweden rejected a
pioneering project to test solar
geoengineering technology environmental
and Indigenous groups issued a letter
highlighting the potential for creating
drastically uneven unpredictable changes
on climate weather and biodiversity and
geopolitical tensions it might awaken
it would cause great changes to our
environment and to our ecosystems and
those precious ecosystems that we are
advocating so hard for to protect and
Safeguard and secure and strengthen a
position like this is one reason that
most solar geoengineering research is
taking place in Labs with models and
simulations turning the debate about
solar geoengineering into one about how
far we should take the research
in January of 2022 400 scientists issued
a letter calling for a non-use agreement
on solar geoengineering it included five
core commitments among them no outdoor
experiments no Public Funding and no
support from International institutions
Professor Pierre Humbert was one of the
scientists who signed it he explained
that the signatories are okay with low
risk research so research that's uh
that's on fundamental climate processes
that doesn't develop the technology that
leads to deployment that can provide
useful information computer simulations
and modeling are Midway through the
Spectrum critics of solar geoengineering
worry that the more modeling we do the
closer we'll get to full-scale
deployment but they acknowledge that
some simulations are useful and a key
part of overall science we can't
eliminate we are pretty clear on the
idea that research that was essentially
technology development that would lead
to deployment was something that the
signatories are opposed to Lily thier
who works at the center for
international environmental law told me
something similar as soon as we let the
genie out of the bottle you know if we
not only just theoretically research but
completely develop certain technology
gonna it will most certainly get used
we've seen that with other Technologies
as well
about a year later in February of 2023
110 scientists including Keith issued a
letter in support of more research into
solar geoengineering they want a robust
International scientific assessment that
includes experiments that could
potentially Advance technology but
stated that while we fully support the
research this does not mean we support
the use of solar geoengineering Tech we
can't find the has the future and force
them never to use these Technologies so
if we make a collective decision now not
to do serious research that doesn't
prevent people employing these
technology in the future it just means
they will employ them with less
knowledge I asked Sarah Doherty who
studies Marine Cloud brightening at the
University of Washington about research
like this doing the research right now
really is important and it's important
to making
Equitable decisions down the road
because the cat's out of the bag people
know these these options exist some
people think we should be going out and
doing them right now so that tells you
how likely it is people 20 years from
now are going to be saying let's go do
this
a big concern both sides agree on is the
negative impact solar geoengineering
could have on decarbonization efforts
and that the tech might act as an excuse
for oil and gas companies to keep
selling fossil fuels to unleash the
technology of solar geoengineering on
the world at a time when we've just
barely started to get people interested
in doing the harbor decarbonization that
will just inevitably increase the
pressure to just take business as usual
I absolutely agree that a risk around
these Technologies is that they will be
exploited by people who want to preserve
emissions but agreeing on the issue
doesn't mean agreeing on the path
forward that is a political concern in
my view it is not an ethical basis for
restricting research on technologies
that are potentially risk reducing
so far Mexico is the only country that's
banned solar geoengineering experiments
while the US is currently developing a
solar geoengineering research plan World
organizations focused on climate are now
starting to make assessments and
recommendations
I can't tell you which one is exactly
right what I can tell you is that each
and every single person I spoke to on
either side of the issue cares deeply
about our future on this planet and
maybe that tension between them is
actually a good thing
because while it doesn't make our path
forward clear it can make us more
thoughtful and rigorous about how to
solve this giant mess we are currently
in
[Music]